veamos si podemos evaluar la integral
indefinida de tangente de x de x y como
siempre te invito a que le pongas pausa
al vídeo e intentes hacerlo por tu
cuenta te voy a dar una ayuda ver si
puedes aplicar la regla de sustitución
bien supongo que ya lo intentaste
hagámoslo juntos la regla y sustitución
nos dice que si tenemos una función
multiplicada por su derivada podemos
aplicarla sin embargo aquí tan solo
vemos una función tangente de x como la
aplicamos aquí siempre que ve una
función como tangente de x secante de x
o con secante de x lo que se me ocurre
es escribir la definición de la función
en términos de seno y cosenos y dado que
contamos con una gran cantidad de
herramientas para operar con cm y coseno
a nuestras mentes por lo menos a la mía
le es más fácil operar así sabemos
entonces que tangente de x es igual a
seno de x sobre coseno de x voy a
reescribir aquí la integral
así es que esto es igual a la integral
de seno de x sobre coseno de x la cual
podemos describir como y esto para darte
una ayuda esto es igual a la integral
seno de x que multiplica a 1 sobre
coseno de x y si no pudiste resolver la
la primera vez
de nueva cuenta ponle pausa el vídeo y
ve que ahora sí la sugerencia sigue
siendo aplica la regla de sustitución
bien a qué me refiero cuando digo la
regla de sustitución revisemos eso antes
de continuar con el ejemplo veamos ya
sabemos que la integral indefinida de
uno entre x de x esto es igual al
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
x + c entonces ahora cuál será la
integral indefinida de f prima de x que
multiplica a 1
/ efe x de x aquí es donde podemos
aplicar el teorema de sustitución
aquí tenemos uno sobre fx si esto está
multiplicado por su derivada ya podemos
integrar con respecto a fx y así es el
integral que queremos resolver
tenemos la derivada multiplicada por 1
la función así es que esto es igual a el
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
fx que es lo que tengo el denominador
más c así es que eso me expande mucho ya
no cabe todo en la pantalla así es que
eso es lo que vamos a aplicar aquí aquí
tenemos que cose no de x coseno dx es fx
esto es fx y aquí no tenemos
precisamente la derivada de coseno dx
que es menos seno de x nosotros tenemos
seno de x pero todo le hacemos como nos
las ingeniamos qué tal si incluimos un
negativo dentro y otro afuera del
integral no la alteramos pues estamos
multiplicando por menos 1 la integral 2
veces lo cual es 1 positivo así es que
menos seno de x aquí forcé un poco este
signo menos dentro del integral menos
seno de x que tenemos aquí ya es f prima
de x ya transformamos seno de x en menos
seno de x lo cual es
efe primer x ya podemos ahora aplicar el
teorema de sustitución
que esto es igual al logaritmo natural
del valor absoluto y aquí nos merecemos
unas pequeñas fanfarrias del valor
absoluto de coseno de x + c y por
supuesto no olvidemos este signo menos
que tenemos por fuera el integral que
hay que incluir aquí y así hemos
concluido hemos obtenido que es un
resultado interesante pues es muy útil
saber cuál es la integral indefinida de
tangente de x es interesante que si se
conecten estas dos funciones así es que
la integral indefinida de tangente de x
es menos el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de coseno de x más c